bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
l'union européenne a donc décidé de
taper du poing sur la table ces mesures
punitives peut-elle peuvent-elles faire
bouger les choses au mali
des sons l'union européenne une décision
qui est dans la suite de celle que
viennent de prendre la cedeao le début
janvier le 9 janvier donc en fait on est
dans un système dans une organisation
générale qui vise à engager globalement
le système politique malien je pense pas
que la décision soit de nature
globalement à faire évoluer les choses
dans le sens d'une d'une réplique dans
le sens d'une une accélération du
processus démocratique vision à monter
les élections conséquences sur les
relations entre l'union européenne et le
mal et on sait que
le rapport est déjà très tendues entre à
la france à bamako
les clubs ne le prennent aujourd'hui
delà des autorités maliennes c'est
qu'elles ont des difficultés globalement
avec l'ensemble des dispositifs
diplomatique autour de la france puisque
notre ambassadeur joël meyer a été été
expulsé il ya quelques jours il est
rentré je crois avant avant-hier donc
l'ensemble des dispositifs encore une
fois de diplomatique autour d'eux mali
et entend survécu ce qui malheureusement
oblige quelque part c'est un peu un peu
comme des as un peu raide car s'il est
le fait de ne pas avoir l'air de porte
de sortie entre guillemets oblige
quelques par les maliens à s'activer
pour trouver de nouveaux de nouveaux
rapports de nouvelles relations avec de
nouveaux acteurs qui parle je pense à la
russie principalement qui aujourd'hui si
vous voulez le les décisions européennes
sous les forces que par les maliens ce
qu'il est vraiment à à céret ou à sérier
oua oua concentrer leurs relations avec
avec l'état russe c'est toute la halle à
l'ambiguïté simuler des décisions
européennes
alors les pays africains ces derniers
tournent à vue voilà une succession de
coups d'état dans plusieurs pays
d'afrique et à chaque fois on a
l'impression que une fois arrivée au
pouvoir les militaires ne veulent plus
le rendre justement à la population
civile est ce une volonté justement de
s'accaparer le pouvoir ou voilà de faire
face à cette menace terroriste qui vise
plusieurs pays
la première question à se poser c'est
pourquoi pourquoi y at-il tant du coup
d'état actuellement dans l'est de
l'afrique de l'ouest principalement
puisque aujourd'hui à part le mali le
burkina faso la guinée conakry et
rappelez vous cette semaine il ya eu la
guinée-bissau le connaît sur un modèle
dans lequel civile et des forces
militaires chassé pour le pouvoir et
pourquoi elles prennent le pouvoir
d'abord souvent dans les pays africains
ce sont les seules grandes force
structurée mais capable sélection lire
les intervenants habituels de des états
mais qui sont capables d'agir ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point c'est
le constat qu'ils font et les
populations font de façon générale c'est
voilà pour la la guinée mais également
bien sûr pour le mali est là et le
burkina faso c'est que concrètement
civils et les populations sont lassés de
la guerre après après une dizaine
d'années de conflits quasiment
ininterrompue avec des pertes en
permanence il est globalement ce qui se
passe c'est que les forces armées si les
cherche à trouver des solutions à ses
premiers points alors après vous
m'interrogez sur le fait qu'ils rentrent
pas de pouvoir ici ils voient un constat
dramatique quant à la sécurité quant à
l'évolution économique du pays et c'est
acceptable traitons traitements ciblés
ils considèrent qu'ils offrent un peu de
temps il est sûr que lorsqu'on connaît
le pouvoir s'il faut rendre le pouvoir
des civils qui eux mêmes n'ont pas été
capables d'assurer d'assurer si vous
voulez c'est le comment dire le
l'évolution en tout cas de régler les
pronos sécurité on parle tout de suite
des problèmes il faut laisser le temps
quand ce que je pense c'est que leur qui
à coup d'état comme ça il faut laisser
le temps au temps il faut il faut leur
donner quelques mois quelques années ça
c'est une discussion qui se mettre en
place avec les autorités de la
transition comme on dit et il est vrai
que home animalier et magna s'est
engagée lors du deuxième coup d'état en
dé l'année dernière s'est engagée à
laurent de cette façon à partir des
élections qui auront lieu au mois de
février prononcer trop poreuse je pense
qu on a peut-être pu quelque part si
vous voulez les les accompagner dans une
évolution plus lente afin de leur faire
un moratoire ou d'ordonner un peu plus
de temps aux six mois un an pour
organiser les élections comme on l'a pas
fait mais les dissidents sont prises je
dirais unilatéralement et donc les
maliens aujourd'hui considèrent qu' ils
vont laisser qu'ils vont y vont quand
ils y vont faire ces élections que dans
quelques années voire un an deux ans
trois ans c'est ce qui rend le skill ce
qui rend la situation inacceptable
aujourd'hui et pour les européens est ce
que c'est une manière aussi de ramener
les maliens la table de négociation pour
arriver à une solution durable notamment
au mali
je ne vois je ne crois pas je pense on
exerce la pression sur eux c'est un
moyen qui est habituel si mais si ça se
fait partout globalement donc je le
prépare lorsque je crains surtout c'est
que sa force les maliens s'il voulait a
accéléré des processus je dirais de vers
le soin d'autres d'autres partenaires
est en fait de rompre définitivement si
vous voulez cette espèce de relation
un peu à peu magique un peu
extraordinaire qui a entre l'europe et
la france bien évidemment et les pays
francophones moi je pense qu'il ya eu ce
que plutôt diplomate dans ma façon de
voir les choses je pense qu'il faut
garder le contact garder ses relations
et je pense que tout tout ce qui est
utile à tom n'est jamais bon si vous
voulez pour les relations
internationales ont étape entre le mali
et le et leur d'autant que le ben ali
encore face à des alliés jeu qu'on les
laisse pas les os les russes qui sont
présents depuis très longtemps la
plupart des peurs des officiers qui vous
rencontrez aux mammites ont été eux
mêmes tout au parti formé en russie donc
ils s'en iront ils ont des relations
bien évidemment avec le avec l'état
russe mais au travers des ventes à des
ventes d'armes par exemple donc encore
une fois concrètement je pense qu'il
faut garder le lien je pense que tout ce
qui fait un peu ce qui bloque les
neuneus n'est pas favorable et ne va pas
en faveur ciblé d'une résolution de la
crise merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir
réagi à sur notre antenne qu'un deuil
engage rappelle que vous êtes
vice-président de l'institut thémis
dédié aux thématiques liées à la paix et
à la sécurité